(El mismo día del ataque de Pearl Harbour,
Japón llevó a cabo un ataque combinado contra
Hong Kong, Filipinas, Tailandia y Malasia.
Fue el día 7 de diciembre de 1941.
Tras tomar el control de Hong Kong, el ejército
japonés internó en campos de prisioneros
a los administradores de la colonia y a muchos
ciudadanos británicos y estadounidenses;
sustituyó el dólar de Hong Kong por el Yen
militar y confiscó todas las instalaciones
de producción y comercio de la ciudad.
Durante los cuatro años de ocupación japonesa,
la economía de Hong Kong se fue a pique,
se arruinó, y la población se redujo a la
mitad.
Pero el día 15 de agosto de 1945, finalmente,
tras la durísima Guerra del Pacífico, se
terminó la Segunda guerra Mundial.
Japón
se rindió y Hong Kong volvió a pasar a manos
de los británicos.
A partir de ese momento comenzaría una nueva
historia, el tiempo del despegue económico.
Un proceso que llevaría a esta ciudad a convertirse
en uno de los territorios más libres y ricos
de toda Asia e, incluso, de todo el planeta.)
Con siete millones y medio
de habitantes y más de 1.200 rascacielos,
Hong Kong ha sido durante las últimas décadas
las gran referencia de prácticamente todo
el continente asiático.
Sin embargo, esto, ha cambiado.
(Veréis, situado en pleno delta del río
de las perlas, la gran zona tecnológica e
industrial de China, Hong Kong vio en 2018
como su vecina, la ciudad de Shenzhen, la
conocida como el Silicon Valley chino, le
arrebata el primer puesto como la ciudad con
la economía más grande del sur de China.)
Así es Hong Kong ni siquiera es ya la mayor
economía entre las ciudades que integran
el delta del río de las perlas.
[Sí…., a ver, esto tiene una pequeña trampa.
Shenzhen tiene algo más de 10 millones de
habitantes, entre 3 y 5 millones más que
Hong Kong, que en términos per cápita sigue
siendo, claro mucho más rica. ]
Pero, amigos, no importa, porque esto es algo
que nos muestra cómo están cambiando las
cosas y cómo Hong Kong se está quedando
rezagada.
Y no es que no la economía de la ciudad no
crezca. Sino que sus vecinos crecen mucho más.
Eso y que mientras sus vecinos, especialmente
Shenzhen se han convertido en importantes
centros tecnológicos e industriales, dónde
han surgido multinacionales tan importantes
como Tencent, DJI o Huawei, Hong Kong se está
convirtiendo en un centro financiero… pero
nada más.
Y la pregunta que hoy cada vez más personas
se hacen es, ¿estaremos ante el ocaso o ante
el renacimiento de Hong Kong?
Sí, sí, habéis escuchado bien. Blanco o
negro.
Atentos.
(LA CIUDAD DE LOS CONTRASTES)
Amigos, turno para vosotros, os hago una pregunta.
¿Estáis preparados?
¿Cual pensais que es la ciudad del mundo
con más ultra ricos viviendo en ella? ¿Con
más personas con patrimonios de más de 30
millones de dólares?
Vale, seguro que muchos habéis pensado en
Nueva York, Londres o tal vez Dubái, ¿Verdad?
Pues… frio, frio. ¡Al río! Habéis fallado
más que el Profesor Bacterio.
("Nueva York eclipsada como la ciudad con
la gente más extremadamente rica. Hong Kong
es hogar de más gente extremadamente rica
que ninguna otra ciudad en el mundo” )
Sí Hong Kong. Hong Kong, amigos,es la ciudad
con más multimillonarios del planeta.
Más de 10.000 residentes en esta ciudad tienen
un patrimonio de más de 30 millones de dólares.
[¿Qué? ¿Cómo te quedas?]
Así que puede que estéis pensando… vamos
a ver… si la ciudad está creciendo entorno
al 3% anual y es la ciudad con más multimillonarios
del mundo… entonces es que las cosas por
aquí van realmente bien, ¿no?
Pues sí… pero no.
Amigos, Hong Kong es un caso paradigmático.
Veréis, por un lado es aparentemente una
ciudad pujante y rica. Un centro financiero
de primer orden mundial.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la Bolsa de
Hong Kong es gigantesca. En ella cotizan más
de 2.300 empresas con un valor de mercado
total de algo más de 4,1 billones, billones
[billones hispanos] de dólares.
Sin embargo al misma tiempo, la ciudad tiene
muchos, muchísimos problemas.
(Sus residentes más pobres cada vez ganan
menos, las tasas de mortalidad infantil están
creciendo, el envejecimiento de la población
avanza a toda velocidad y un porcentaje enorme
de la población vive en viviendas que no
son propias de un país desarrollado.
En muchos casos en espacios minúsculos sin
ni siquiera ventanas o con ventanas sin ninguna
posibilidad de ventilación.Vamos, auténticos
zulos. )
Amigos, los espacios más claustrofóbicos
del mundo están en esta ciudad.
Y esto tiene mucho que ver con que lo que
tendría que ser una acomodada clase media
realmente no lo sea.
(“Casi la mitad de los pisos de Hong Kong
se alquilan por 2.550 dólares al mes, el
70% de la mediana de los ingresos por hogar)
(Según la compañía de investigación Demographia,
el precio de las casas es 20,9 veces mayor
que los ingresos medios por hogar en Hong
Kong, comparado con las 3,9 veces de Estados
Unidos y las 4,3 de Canadá. Takeshi Kihara,
redactor de Nikkei Asian Review)
Pero, amigos, de todo esto ya os hablamos
en un pasado vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
[Y no, lo siento, ya os adelanto que en todo
esto no tiene nada que ver el capitalismo
salvaje, ni la codicia de las grandes empresas,
ni el exceso de población, ni nada por el
estilo.
Si no más bien el gobierno, porque en Hong
Kong la inmensa mayor parte del suelo y buena
parte de las viviendas son del gobierno, son
públicas.]
Pero, un momento, no penséis que aquí termina
todo, mi mucho menos.
En Octubre de 2018, el banco de inversión
Nomura presentó un informe en el que alertaba
que el riesgo de que Hong Kong pueda padecer
una crisis financiera en los próximos años
se ha disparado.
(“Hong Kong se encuentra en una zona peligrosa
para una nueva crisis financiera )
[Entre otras cosas porque buena parte de la
población ha asumido préstamos enormes para
poder acceder a una vivienda. De tal forma
que un porcentaje muy importante de los residentes
en Hong Kong, particularmente jóvenes profesionales
están hasta el cuello de préstamos hipotecarios.]
(“Hong Kong tiene mucha deuda y un mercado
inmobiliario sobrecalentado. Desde el 2008,
los precios inmobiliarios se han disparado
un 125% en términos reales y el ratio de
deuda del sector privado no financiero ha
superado el 299% del PIB.)
Y, claro si a esto le sumamos que los salarios
no crecen y que su economía es muy dependiente
de China cuya crecimiento parece estar desacelerándose, el cocktel podría llegar a ser de aupa.
(Me quiero marchar porque Hong Kong ya no
es lo que era. Mi plan es hacer un máster
en Canadá, encontrar un trabajo y empezar
una nueva vida”. - Jonathan Chan, un estudiante
hongkonés de 24 años )
Y es que claro… eso de matarse a trabajar
con jornadas interminables, para vivir en
una casa minúscula y que encima tras pagar
la hipoteca o el alquiler el salario se quede
en muy poca cosa… pues cómo que no, que
no invita mucho al optimismo, ¿no os parece?
[Y luego encima no puedes montar nada porque
cualquier sitio para poder montar algo es
carísimo. Peor que peor.]
Pues eso amigos es precisamente lo que cada
vez más jóvenes hongkoneses piensan… Mirad.
(“Según un estudio de 2018 de la Chinese
University de Hong Kong, el 51% de la gente
entre 18 y 30 años dice que están pensando
en marcharse del territorio”. Takeshi Kihara,
redactor de Nikkei Asian Review )
Más de la mitad de los jóvenes querrían
vivir su vida en otro lugar. No me digáis
que eso no es preocupante.
Y luego tenemos que tener en cuenta la cada
vez mayor injerencia política de China y
las crecientes restricciones a las libertades
políticas:
(“Hong Kong prohíbe un partido pro-independencia
mientras China refuerza su control. El Hong
Kong National Party es prohibido en interés
de la “seguridad nacional”. )
(La libertad de prensa en Hong Kong en cuestión
al denegarse visa a periodista del Financial Times.)
En fin ya lo véis, creo que no sería descabellado
decir que estamos ante algo así como el ocaso
del esplendor de Hong Kong, esa ciudad,
que deslumbró al mundo convirtiéndose en
todo un centro financiero, comercial, e incluso
cultural…
Porque durante décadas Hong Kong, incluso,
tuvo la tercera mayor industria del cine de
todo el mundo, [ Ojo, una industria de la
que se llegó a pensar podría rivalizar con
la mismísima Hollywood.]
Sin embargo, esperad un momento… porque
también hay quien defiende que... muy bien
todo esto ya se ha producido pero que ahora
la ciudad está a punto de experimentar todo
un renacimiento.
¿Estarán los mejores tiempo de Hong Kong
al caer?
(EL NUEVO HONG KONG CHINO)
Os lo hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik:
al presidente chino todo eso de 1 país 2 sistemas
no le hace ninguna gracia. Xi Jinping está
empeñado en reducir la autonomía política
de Hong Kong.
Pues bien, para lograrlo ha presentado un
gran plan: el proyecto del área metropolitana
de la Gran Bahía.
(El presidente chino quiere convertir todo
el delta del Rio de las Perlas, donde se sitúan
ciudades como Hong Kong, Macao, Shenzhen o
Guangzhou, en una gran área metropolitana
perfectamente conectada y con una enorme integración
económica.
Y ojo porque estamos hablando de más 70 millones
de personas y un PIB que en 2030 según las
estimaciones de Morgan Stanley superará los
3 billones de dólares, más grande que la
economía del Reino Unido.)
De momento los grandes proyectos de infraestructuras
ya son una realidad: se ha inaugurado un tren
de alta velocidad entre Hong Kong, Shenzhen
y Guangzhou, y también el puente más largo
del mundo entre Hong Kong y Macao.
Una conexión ni más ni menos que de 55km
de largo, que por supuesto ha costado un dineral.
¿El problema? Que el gobierno chino quiere
que toda esta integración permita poner fin
a la autonomía de Hong Kong.
Y es que entre otras cosas, aunque formalmente
son un país, las regulaciones, las leyes
y los tribunales son diferentes en Hong Kong
que en la China continental y entre los dos
territorios hay fronteras y aduanas…
Así que para que el área metropolitana realmente
funcionase pues parece que tendría que producirse
cierta armonización… lo que por supuesto
significa que Hong Kong sea cada vez más
China y que cuando expire su autonomía en
el 2047 esta pues no se renueve o se renueve
de forma muy limitada. ¿Lo véis?
Pues aún hay más.
(En todo un giro espectacular de los acontecimientos
China ha nombrado a Hong Kong como el Centro
Nacional de Tecnología e Innovación del
sur de China.
El gobierno chino ha comenzado a financiar
por primera vez proyectos de investigación
en las universidades de Hong Kong, ha exigido
al gobierno de este territorio que duplique
su presupuesto en I+D y a que apruebe un programa
para atraer científicos y tecnólogos de
todo el mundo.)
Pero… ¿Por qué diantres hace esto China?
Pues amigos, porque Hong Kong tiene una enorme
ventaja respecto al continente: es considerado
una economía de mercado y no está sujeto
a restricciones a sus importaciones.
Es decir, las empresas de Hong Kong pueden
comprar lo que les dé la gana, incluidos
bienes de alta tecnología que pueden tener
aplicaciones tanto civiles como militares,
productos que el gobierno y las empresas chinas
no pueden comprar.
Es decir, que China quiere aprovecharse del
status de Hong Kong para impulsar sus planes
de desarrollo tecnológico.
Si lo consigue estupendo, y si Estados Unidos
y el resto de potencias occidentales imponen
restricciones a Hong Kong y terminan con su
estatus de puerto libre echarán a la ciudad
aún más en manos de China que estará encantada
de invertir miles de millones en este territorio
y asumir el control total.
En fin, amigos, ya lo véis. Es difícil prever
si estamos ante el ocaso o ante el renacimiento
de Hong Kong, pero lo que sí parece claro,
es que Hong Kong cada vez será más China.
Pero ahora turno para ti, ¿Crees que veremos
los mejores tiempos de Hong Kong?
Dejame tu respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like y no olvides suscirbirte a VisualPolitik
¡Qué es gratis!
Un saludo y hasta la próxima